The domain of this function is all the real numbers, which we write in interval
notation as spanning from negative infinity to positive infinity. Now, there are
no domain restrictions on this function imposed by the math itself because every
value of x that we could plug in from all the real numbers, is going to cause
the function to spit out a real value of y as well. So, what is its range?
Another good question. Well, we can see from the graph, that as x decreases, y
is continuing to decrease as well. And as x increases, y is continuing to
increase. If we look at the function, the higher the value of x that we plug in,
the higher and higher and higher, y is going to go. And similarly, the lower the
x value we input, the smaller this number over here is going to get for the
output. So, the range is also all the real numbers.